the family of amari nicholson the
two-year-old who went missing in las
vegas
is pleading for the return of that child
last seen
near paradise and twain joe moeller
there with what the family has to say
about this missing child joe brian
earlier this afternoon omaree's aunt
from the dad's side said they are
increasing the reward
from 20 000 to 30 thousand dollars as
the search continues for amari who was
last seen here two days ago at this
complex near
twain in paradise according to amari's
mom taylor nicholson a two-year-old
was taken from this complex two days ago
when she when he went missing
she says she was in colorado helping her
mother who was recently injured
nicholson's boyfriend terrell rhodes who
i also spoke with
says he was watching amari at the time
but he says someone claiming to be the
toddler's aunt came by and
took the child he's a helpless
two-year-old he's tiny and can't fight
back he doesn't know where he's at
doesn't know where mommy and daddy
are because we're the only two people
that he knows and
he he needs medicine he you know he's
scared
amari's father sergio hayes lives in
reno i spoke to his sisters in
california who are putting up the reward
they say no one knows where amari is and
according to them
nobody from the family has them they
tell me they can't get in contact with
amari's mother so now they are worried
we don't know anything about the last
couple of days
that amari has seen and the mother is
not helping us
at all and we're trying to work with the
police
but because of this false narrative the
police aren't really able to help either
because there's no search there's no
amber alert
this afternoon metro said they are still
looking into the disappearance and need
information
from the public now back out here live
both amari's mother and aunt say
both separately are putting together
their very own search teams for this if
you have any information you're asked to
call
the metro reporting live near paradise
and twain joe mullen babies now